[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where you
are going to find the most carefulist
boys careful boys in all the land sure
i'm very proud of that
today's burning question is
when is it okay to hit a woman oh spicy
um
never
[Applause]
let's go let's go let's go
ever never
never is the answer
[Applause]
don't do it
don't do it
taking a seat
[Applause]
never
don't ever do it
[Applause]
it's wrong
[Applause]
yeah we said it
say it again guys
never oh i'm saying it okay i'm saying
it
he's walking
[Applause]
hope you're watching women haters
yeah take that sausage festival no
hidden women
not happening
[Applause]
keep your hands to yourself dudes
everybody in one frame everybody wants
frame
[Applause]
women's rights
[Applause]
hey suck my dick if you want to
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's what i'm talking about
i'm clapping here
this is literally what i'm talking about
literally oh yeah
i've been trying to say this for years
so true thank you thank you for saying
that thank you sure thank you for being
brave guys thank you for being afraid
you're welcome
never
and if your show didn't make this video
why didn't they make this video yeah
yeah what are you guys why didn't you
make this video are you guys for
violence
[Applause]
this is why i'm so glad to be a part of
this group
i'm glad we're in solidarity
[Applause]
don't even think about it
never thought about it
yeah we're not being very careful boys
right now i guess
whatever
[Applause]
i don't know if i can do this for 15
more minutes 17 more minutes you guys
17. we're going for the guinness world
record longest clap ever
never
don't even think about it don't [ __ ]
think about it dude
not on our watch
nice try pal no wait no
the best thing is you know the guys who
would who would have done that they're
still watching this they're just fuming
they're going like
damn it
we hope you're watching this i hope
you're angry
[Applause]
not us buddy
not today
not yesterday not tomorrow
hey maybe yesterday
not today yeah not tomorrow
think again tough guy
never means never means that not yet
that's nice
never means from now on yeah there it is
right this moment
unless they make it legal or not oh yeah
if they make it legal it's fine yeah
it's totally fine
yeah that's the law
is it just this country or like what if
you go somewhere else we're going
worldwide worldwide worldwide
prestige worldwide the movement
we're looking at you iran it starts here
it starts here what about when we go to
mars
[Music]
face wise okay interstellar interspeller
black galactic [ __ ] aliens
what about the metaverse
oh [ __ ] the metabolism yeah yeah
definitely especially
not the metaverse
[Applause]
how about uh what about transgenders in
the us ufc
[Applause]
whatever they identify with whatever
they want whatever they choose
yeah still a discussion whatever they
decide
what about if you're being attacked and
they're bigger than you and you're
afraid
nope
[Applause]
what if you're a four-foot man and it's
a 6-2 woman and she has the biceps of 10
dudes and she has a spear
nope if she has a vagina you stay away
stay away
what if you're a husband
and you're fighting against wonder woman
no she has a vagina i believe never
does
[Applause]
regardless never never
not on our watch
[Applause]
all right guys 14 more minutes 14 more
minutes
is he chugging a red bull
how did he get that
not by beating his wife
oh yeah uh-huh
i second that
[Applause]
wow thank you did i ever beat my wife i
used to
will i do it again never
never
never amen wait wait what are you used
to that's [ __ ] weird
you're part of our movement dude this is
gonna make us look like [ __ ]
i i was a changed man i used to i found
great joy in it
but then i was like what am i doing in
my life i thought
it was never yeah i thought we never
done it no i thought we're never gonna
do it oh
like this moment i didn't know you're
one of them i think we need to clarify
like how recent though like how recent
dude you're gonna [ __ ] discredit the
whole program we didn't know that it was
like two moons ago tell me we just
wasted like seven minutes of clapping
seven minutes of work for this movement
and now you're like undercutting the
whole [ __ ] movement what the [ __ ]
barf there's two moons you guys it's
like who the [ __ ] counts in moons what
are you a werewolf yeah what is that
what's a month he's chinese it's lunar
new year he [ __ ] uses the moon
calendar oh so it says two years ago is
that two two years or two days i don't i
don't know i don't know what kind of you
go based off i'm not gonna judge you i'm
not gonna judge my camera you go off of
hey when you said you were beating your
wife though were you beating those
[Applause]
[Music]
that's
cheeks
that's okay always
that's pretty cool man
you brother okay i never got it the good
on that one
i never doubted you bro
with consent beat that [ __ ] up yeah
yeah being cheeks is fine i think in a
respectable way though
an embarrassment
consent get out of those chicks
[Applause]
good man never ever
that's pretty cool man
now while we're alive
[Applause]
i'm so proud of you guys by the way
if joe and bart don't clap during the ad
read
i'll be so [ __ ] the movement's over
i'll be so [ __ ] pissed
i'll do it audio wise do you think this
is going to sound pretty good really
good
[Applause]
can people hear us right now over there
yeah you know just just should we go a
little quieter for the sake of audio
just like like uh do subtitles like your
small okay and then the subtitles
i'm clapping faster than any of you
because my feelings are this intense oh
yeah
never yeah thank you i want to walk
around and get a felt more hype
yeah
celebrating again all right let's go
let's all turn around
never y'all just never do it come on
let's take it
that's what jk news stands for so loud
stood up for this standing forward
this has only been 10 minutes long
because
it should be it should be so much longer
this is a forever feeling though
you can't believe ryan hasn't turned out
yet
i feel like i'm a member of a north
korean audience
i don't get it
sit back down though i'm gonna sit back
down
that's cool with you guys all right
i'm gonna sit back down okay
[Applause]
yeah
yeah
just don't do it just don't do it don't
[ __ ] do it don't even think about it
how hard is it
all
right
[Applause]
i'm done
i've never even been close dude you know
never never close
not oh [ __ ]
don't show weakness joe because you
juiced too hard a moment ago man you
went through it space it out but yeah
it's like it's the long game we're
playing dude
we're playing along i got a clap for the
women that have been that have been
[ __ ]
falling soldiers but not by us
not by us never not by us he's gonna
play his arcade
he wants to take it out
are you firing up the arcade or come on
dude
but you're still going to clap though
right yeah no i want to be part of the
movie just give me a second yeah yeah
i'm checking this out hey you're not
going to beat up any women over there
are you you're not going to take your
characters don't be hitting chung
[Applause]
home stretch boys i hope if you're still
watching this because you you believe in
the movement
if you if you exit out you don't believe
in the movie oh i'm sorry
not because this made you uncomfortable
[Applause]
this must be the honestly most important
moment of my jk career yeah all of ours
[Applause]
sounds like any other messages you guys
want to send while we're doing this as
well there's only one message that's in
right now and that's never never
you said it anthony
i'm about to start sweating
my hands taking a beating dude but not
the women oh
unless it's their boutiques
[Applause]
it really is a marathon in there
vlogging is dying out guys come on bring
it back in come on yeah let's do it
let's go
one for the women
for the women
we're not gonna let it happen
[Applause]
he's playing more compact
[Applause]
challenge
for
anti-domestic abuse we send it to you
you send it to you
people out there
[Applause]
let this be a message to all you
[ __ ] out there
wait you're sonia right
because every 20 minutes another man
wants to beat a woman you should be
wrong wrong side guess what you should
be sonya
steve
wrong side
steve
[Applause]
hey the wrong guy no
uh
but you're beating on women over there
oh she's just a sprite
it's not going against her movement hey
dude you can't be
you know hey how do i uppercut
oh my god you are making her bleed
hey dude
she's not doing anything to fight back
why are you sub zero now i don't even
know
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you